mais d'abord pas toujours simple d'être
vacciné contre le coc vite 19 quand on
habite à la campagne constat par exemple
des élus de la petite commune de
champigny sur veude qui ont écrit au
président de la république pour pointer
les déboires de la vaccination en milieu
rural alors quelle est la situation en
val de loire
exemple à vendôme et château renault
avec paul boyer le gymnase du jeu de
paume à blanc est le principal méga
centres de vaccination du loir et cher
mais qu'en est il des communes plus
reculées comment se rendre dans un média
centre lorsqu'on habite en zone rurale
pour toucher ces patients de la campagne
un nouveau centre va ouvrir lundi
prochain à vendôme avec un objectif de
5000 vaccination par semaine il va
permettre de combler une lacune dans le
nord du département
on a un maillage un maillage territorial
important mais au-delà de ces de ces
centres de vaccination qui vaccinent en
général quand même beaucoup moins une
personne puisqu'il ya aussi beaucoup
moins de demandes
il y avait il y avait nécessité de
mettre en place des gros centre un
centre situé dans un local mis à
disposition par la commune fracture
numérique isolement social problèmes de
transport autant de difficultés qui
touchent les populations rurales avec ce
centre c'est la vaccination qui se
rapproche des populations et vient
compléter les centres éphémère déjà
mises en place ou effectivement c'est
compliqué y compris de se déplacer pour
certains venir jusqu'à vendôme à blois
ou ailleurs donc elle était nécessaire
de les aider avec des centres éphémère
et faciliter les déplacements avec des
systèmes de transport on arrive
maintenant sur des tranches d'âge où la
mobilité est plus facile je dis pas
qu'elle est simple mais elle est plus
facile d méga centre pour certaines
communes mais d'autres sont restés sur
la touche
c'est le cas en indre-et-loire de
chateaurenaud commune de 5000 habitants
la mère s'est battu pour l'ouverture
d'un vaccinodromes en vain
malheureusement malgré notre demande
avec les médecins les infirmiers
nous étions prêts elle a donc décidé de
mettre en place un système de bus pour
accompagner les personnes âgées dans les
centres de vaccination situé à amboise
et un ippon pierre à 30 minutes de la
commune petit minibus 9 places
alors bien sûr il monte à trois ou
quatre personnes parce qu'en effet nous
sommes un territoire rural les problèmes
de mobilité
voilà nous y sommes confrontés comme
brigitte dupuis de nombreux maires se
sentent oubliés dans cette campagne de
vaccination face à cela la plupart mise
sur une vaccination mobile en se
déplaçant chez les personnes isolées
afin de ne pas les abandonner